نتابع الان بالنسبه للمناطيد العسكريه ذات
العاكسات حيله هي جديده تستخدمها روسيا في
اوكرانيا وقياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اكدت وجودها في اجوائها لنتحدث عن هذه
المناطيد المناطيس ذات العاكسات هي تقنيه
قديمه لكنها فعاله جدا خلال الحروب لانها
تدفع بالدفاعات الجويه للعدو ان تكشف عن
نفسها وفق الخبراء ايضا هذه العاكسات هي
هدف مثالي من يكتشفها الرادار الذي نتابعه
هنا هي تضمن عوده اشعه الرادار في الاتجاه
المعاكس تماما ما يعطي علامه واضحه على
شاشه هذا الرادار ايضا بماذا تستخدم هذه
العاكسات تستخدم لفحص الرادار عن بعد
وايضا كهداف كاذبه على سبيل المثال تم
استخدام عاكسات
جدا عن الجسور في خرسون للتشويشي على
الصواريخ
المهاجمه ايضا خبراء يقولون ان الهدف
الاخر من اطلاق المناطيد ما هو الا زياده
العبء على نظام الدفاع الجوي الذي ايضا
طبعا نظام الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني قبل اي
هجوم مكثف بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
ايضا ان اسقاط مناطيد رخيصه بصواريخ غربيه
باهظه الثمن امر ايضا غير مربح من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه فهو مكلف الحيله الروسيه
باستخدام المناطيد ذات العاكسات ايضا نجحت
في اوكرانيا لانها دفعت بها الى استنفاذ
ذخيره انظمه الدفاع الجوي التابعه لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الامر الذي سيؤدي الى مشكلات
كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه في المستقبل
ودائما وفق الخبراء
[موسيقى]